he-man is back and he still has the
power now that masters of the universe
revelation is out on netflix many
viewers will want to look back at the
original show for more muscle-bound
action we're here to catch you up on
lore and anything else you may have
forgotten about
when most people think of he-man it's
about muscles action and the fights
against skeletor to save eternia each
episode creates a new conflict that
sends the hero into battle to help
someone or keep the peace but that can't
be all that the titular character does
with his time right he-man was
eventually given an alternate identity
in the form of prince adam within the
pages of the comics this was kept a
secret from many of the supporting cast
so that skeletor couldn't simply kill
his foe while he wasn't powered up but
it also gave the character a weakness
and created some entertaining story
moments when adam couldn't easily slip
away to transform or had to make excuses
to exit a battle so his alter ego could
help out during the classic shows
episodes viewers are given a few small
glimpses into adam's duties as a member
of the royal family attending events
like the joust and watching performances
from many faces and other entertainers
as well as other small diplomatic
outings when those duties aren't taking
up his free time the prince is seen
training or more often opting to skip
these lessons with tila to nap or enjoy
other leisure activities
for a series that takes place on eternia
everyone would be forgiven for assuming
there were no earthlings in the story
but that's not true the show sees its
fair share of people from the planet
mostly in the form of kids as we saw in
the christmas special however a couple
of members from the main cast are hiding
that secret origin as well queen marlena
he-man's mother was originally an
astronaut from earth who was thrown off
course after meteors hit her ship the
rainbow explorer this detour to eternia
was supposed to last a few days but
after we are shown a flashback of this
in the episode the rainbow warrior she
explains that love took hold instead
this sequence might have meant more had
she not dropped a random back on earth
line during the joust earlier but it's
still an intriguing revelation marlena
gets to show off her piloting skills and
save the day in this adventure while
prince adam is stuck without his powers
temporarily at least this means that
prince adam is also half earthling and
even he as he-man is shocked to see that
it was his mother that freed them
meaning it is unlikely many other than
king randor knew much of her past as a
captain of the stars this is also the
episode where queen marlena not so
subtly hints that she knows who her son
truly is
adam
a mother always knows her own son
and what he is capable of doing
his name is a cringe-inducing attempt at
a pun but the backstories for the comics
tried to make manny faces more serious
giving him the origin of a tortured
actor transformed by one of skeletor's
potions and given split personalities
the character would make only two main
appearances and a couple of cameos in
the show leaving more of an imprint with
his gimmick than time on screen he was
originally going to pop in for a side
gag in the episode into the abyss but
was cut to help the tone those who do
recall manny faces remember him as a
hero fighting alongside he-man or at
least are aware of his reputation as the
greatest actor in eternia but in the
mystery of many vases viewers are also
shown that he began on the wrong side of
the law terrorizing people smaller than
him even if he wasn't purely evil manny
faces tells he-man that these acts were
because others were afraid of him
fearful of his abilities and shunned him
for this in his own words this led him
to be cruel toward everyone and steal
from them after a run-in with skeletor
and beastman who abused him for their
own purposes he-man and tila helped free
the future actor and orco even gave
manny faces his name
tila is arguably one of the most
interesting characters in the he-man
universe but having several changes made
to her backstory and altering the
relationship she shares with the group
for various incarnations can make it
difficult to keep up with her in the
original mini comics tila was a clone of
the sorceress created by skeletor an
element that was probably inserted to
help explain the armor on the original
action figure in other versions matt at
arms is her biological father there's
also a theory that fisto might actually
be her dad and in the 1983 cartoon
duncan adopts tila and keeps the
identity of her mother a secret which is
revealed in the episode tila's quest
here tila gets a bit envious of prince
adam's relationship with queen marlena
and sets off to find out who her mother
really is by seeking the oracle being a
bit rash tila heads off to a dangerous
place by herself and runs a foul of
merman and a sea monster but he-man
shows up to help she goes through all of
this and discovers that her mother is
none other than the source risk only to
have those memories erased the knowledge
is treated as an incredibly important
tidbit that she can't know but now
he-man is aware of it also this is
brought up one other time in tila's
triumph where she temporarily assumes
the role of the sorceress
many viewers were not fond of orco this
could be because the character didn't
appear in the initial run of the toy
line having been created for the cartoon
or perhaps it's because he typically
played the role of comedy relief he is
the king's royal buffoon after all orco
was a klutz never really able to do his
magic correctly often hindering the
heroes on their missions and constantly
damaging man at arm's lap somehow he's
still one of prince adam's closest
allies it isn't surprising that most
fans were more upset at the lack of
battle cat in the live-action film than
not seeing orco he's a powerful
character even if he has trouble getting
his spells to work properly as a trollin
orco possesses a mastery over matter
creation his hat opens up into a
dimensional space where he can keep any
number of items as well as an extra hand
comes out of there and his teleportation
powers allow him to easily escape many
traps his potent tricks do seem to work
somewhat better back in his home
dimension where the laws of physics work
differently there is a medallion that
helps him as well but some of these
points contradict themselves as the show
progresses more importantly in creatures
from the tar swamp orco saves adam and
cringer at a young age before they had
their powers
he-man was originally supposed to wield
a battle axe back when he was in toy
form but looking back now he wouldn't
seem right without his power sword the
masters of the universe toys also came
with two swords and these had to be put
together to unlock castle greyskull in
the 80s however shows came under fire
from parent groups and politicians alike
prepared to blame much of society's ills
on the pop culture of the day as
preemptive measures skeletor got a staff
he-man held back on his swordplay and
other creative decisions were made to
walk a tightrope ensuring that the
series could be kid-friendly yet still
be appealing to the older crowd as well
tayla could you put your finger here for
a second
[Music]
he-man barely uses his fists let alone
his sword and most of his aggressive
actions are levied against large
monsters or robots whenever the hero is
dealing with humanoid type characters
his tactics become more about subduing
the enemies his preferred method is
usually to throw large rocks or simply
pick the perpetrator up and toss them
public service announcements often
shortened to psas have a long and
complicated history that can arguably be
traced back to the civil war filmation
is often mentioned for modernizing these
messages with their work on fat albert
and the cosby kids and he-man the latter
almost had to have these little lessons
due to how closely parents related the
show to violence and the producers tried
hard to balance out the program running
130 episodes the show covered a lot of
ground with these messages so it makes
sense they don't all land quite right a
few are uncomfortable and others are
just plain silly consider for instance
the psa that had ram men telling kids
not to run their heads into things
trying to use your head the way i do is
not only dangerous
it's dumb others were a bit more serious
and included a wide variety of pertinent
topics such as inappropriate touching
ageism judging people based on their
appearances not taking shortcuts for
wealth and power accepting failures and
learning from mistakes within the
episodes themselves were some solid
examples of needing to have faith and
that even he-man can lose his confidence
which the creators say paid off based on
stories fans told them years later
it's no secret that filmation was
banking on he-man and the masters of the
universe to help put the company on the
map and to make sure everything worked
out the way they wanted it costs had to
be kept low this pride in an
american-made show kept under budget led
to cuts all around with voice acting and
animation taking the largest hits as
anyone who watches the show can hear
various small characters have familiar
voices and zoomed in shots frequently
take the place of actual animation as
reused assets rewound motions and
replayed sequences became the norm
speaking of cutting corners the
character of orco originally had another
name gorpo which can still be heard in
some portuguese translations of the show
this late alteration seems to come from
a financial standpoint instead of a
creative one because if the character
had a large letter g imprinted on his
clothing it would be harder to flip
footage of him and make scenes look
different without having to redraw the
floating magician this brings into
question how many other changes might
have happened all in the name of saving
a few dollars even if orco is the better
name
most folks don't think of great writing
or production value when recalling
he-man and the masters of the universe
but the truth is that the program had
some incredibly skilled
behind-the-scenes talent not only was
there a tremendous group of voice actors
who brought the characters to life many
of them having to talk to themselves in
a majority of the scenes but other
voices had to be filled in by one of the
founders of filmation lou shimer
additionally his wife and daughter even
lent a hand making it quite a tight-knit
group the energetic music was handled by
haim ziban and shooky levy giants with
stellar resumes in the world of
children's programming behind the scenes
was bruce tim now known as the mind
behind some of dc comic's greatest
animated projects one of his earliest
gigs was as a background artist and
designer for he-man while he was also
given a chance to work with the mini
comics some of his fellow comic book
brethren were present to help on scripts
with pauldini and j michael strzinski
working on the show early in their
careers star trek scribe dc fontana
contributed an episode featuring the
origin of battle cat as well even if
children's show trappings restricted
what could be done no one could ever say
that he-man didn't have a wealth of
talent behind him
masters of the universe revelation is
attempting to give fans a proper
continuation to the 80s cartoon but it's
not the first time this has been
attempted although rarely remembered
there was an attempt at a direct sequel
that mutated into its own strange oddity
sales for the toy line had begun to
decline drastically by 1986 and it was
evident that the franchise needed some
sort of rejuvenation this came in the
form of a redesigned set of toys which
would require a new show to help sell
them like last time enter the new
adventures of he-man this show uprooted
adam from eternia placing him instead on
the ultra high-tech planet primus
leaving most of the cast behind skeletor
did tag along to remain his nagging
nemesis this near-complete re-haul of
he-man featured a protagonist that
didn't look like the muscle-bound
warrior kids were accustomed to seeing
as well as one of the worst designs for
skeletor other than the upgraded visuals
almost everything else was worse and the
show is often remembered if at all as
the weakest of the franchise somehow new
adventures ran for 65 episodes there
were rumors of a second season that
would send adam back to eternia but
instead the 90s led he-man into relative
obscurity with masters of the universe
revelation perhaps it is finally time
once again for he-man to have the power
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite animated shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]